Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing where we left off last night
at verse number
40 41 and 42. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala tells us about the people of
paradise those exempt from their guilt
exempt from the being held hostage by
their own sins because of their
repentance because of their dutifulness
to Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us about the
people of paradise
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala that the
people of the right will be in paradise
in gardens very lush gardens and therein
they will be asking the people of the
hellfire the criminals the mujerimin
The wordjim
[Silence]
alimat.
Quran.
[Silence]
The word
is plural for which is a criminal. It's
someone who has done an incredibly
heinous and egregious
thing. Someone who not only has done
it, has committed a vile act, but it's
somebody who is become that has
become that person's nature.
And so this is considered to be a mujim
in the Quran. But in the Quran
there are major and minor of many of
these things. So for instance hypocrisy
in Islam we have major hypocrisy and
minor hypocrisy.
Major kufur and minor kufur. Major shik
and minor shik. Majoram
and minoram. An entire books have been
written on discussing the differences
between these things.
But
a criminal act can be committed
but the person can still be a Muslim.
Whereas Allah may refer to others as
criminals. When he refers to them as the
criminals, they are the people who are
the people of the hellfire. That is
another term for the damned. Those who
will never leave the gates of hell.
May Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala protect
us. And so the people of paradise, they
will ask these these criminals
be suffer. What has landed you in this
hellfire and this damnation that you are
all in right now? Now, we we left off
last night on an interesting question
that paradise is so vast and so high and
the hellfire is so deep. How is it that
the people of hell and the people of
paradise are speaking to each other? How
is it that some people will fall into
the flames of hell for 70 years not
reaching its bottom while others will
rise thousands of levels in paradise yet
they will still have this dialogue. How
is that? The question itself is flawed
because the question itself is
presupposing
that the way that people communicate and
the way that time and distance and sound
works in paradise and hell is the same
as the way that these things work here
on this earth. But these things couldn't
be more different. The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam tells us of
incredible things in paradise things
that literally are mindbending
things that can only
be imagined as a concept but can't
really be visualized
because the human being we visualize
things based on experience
if I tell you for instance the word
elephant
a picture of an elephant just popped up
in everyone's head. Now, this elephant
is based on what? Something you've seen
in the past. But if I described it to
you, it would be something that you
attach to another memory. Paradise is
unlike anything that we have experienced
here in this earth. And so, it's not
possible, no matter how vivid the
description, for us to truly
conceptualize paradise. However, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us about
things that seem to be impossible
that are considered normal and common
place in paradise.
For instance, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us in
[Silence]
very strange two opposites.
He tells us that the people of paradise
will drink from goblets and vessels
that are silver at its purest,
but they are transparent crystal.
So they are silver, but a silver that is
transparent glass. You can see
through it crystal clear. Now, how is
that possible? Silver is quite literally
the opposite of crystal. If you look at
how mirrors used to be made. Mirrors
would be made using silver. We'd take
very pure silver and then put glass over
it because silver is known for its
density and that it is reflective. It is
not transparent. You can't see through
silver. But in paradise
there is silver that is clear as
crystal, clear as glass. How is this?
That's saying it's day and night at
the same time or that something is black
and white at the same time. The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam in the narration of
mentions that when he was brought before
the main tree from which all of paradise
is built around and all other trees
sprout from. that its leaves were like
the ears of elephants and that its
fruits were the sides of Alad, which is
a a a big giant kind of vase made out
of pottery that they used to cool water
in. Would be about the size of a small
fridge,
right? And he said,
He said, "And then the tree started to
shape, shift, and change into colors
that I can't even describe because they
don't exist on this earth here today."
In paradise, the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam describes to us
that a person will see
things that seem to be impossible and
almost unimaginable. In the narration of
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam said
[Silence]
He said
that in paradise,
the palaces of paradise place.
You if you are inside of them, you will
be able to simultaneously see the
outside. And if you are outside of the
palace, you can see and experience the
inside of the palace simultaneously.
The person will be seeing both inside
and outside the palace at the same time.
How is that possible?
It's unimaginable because the way that
vision works here in this earth is a
straight line. We receive with our eyes
you know light that bounces off of
things and gives us sight. This is not
how paradise works. The prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam mentions to us
that a man in paradise will have a
dominion that is 2,000 years traveled.
This is the size of paradise.
And he will be able to see all of his
dominion simultaneously at the same time
from wherever he sits. And so a dialogue
between the people of hell and the
people of paradise while they are
simultaneously
eons
and light years apart but at the same
time speaking as if they are next to
each other. This is something that we do
not have here on this earth. However,
this is the nature of paradise and the
hellfire in the hereafter.
that they will ask the people of the
hellfire,
what has landed you in this damnation,
in this damned place, in this very
forsaken place, this wretched existence
of the hellfire.
They will respond, the people of hell,
they will respond.
The first thing they will say, we were
not of the people who made salah.
Now notice something here and that is
that they won't argue.
The people of hell, they don't argue.
Any time in the Quran when Allah
mentions the people of hell or the
hypocrites when they come before Allah,
they may argue likel argued in paradise
when he was commanded to bow to Adam.
They may come up with some argument and
Allah will then close their mouths and
cause their extremities to speak on
their behalf. But in the hellfire, no
one argues.
No one argues. No one excuses himself.
Every time the people of hell speak,
they will say, "We're guilty. We are
guilty. We are guilty." Why? Because
that is the only thing that these
wretched
souls
understand that makes them truthful.
The only thing that makes them truthful
is pain that reaches the core of their
soul. That is it. Any other time they
are taken away from that pain, it is
immediately covered up with arrogance,
with anger, with jealousy, with
laziness, with desire, any other time.
But as soon as they are touched into the
hellfire,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala said
that when they receive just a just a
glimpse, just a blow of the winds of the
hellfire, immediately they will say,
"Yahweh."
They will say, "We're guilty. Woe to us.
We were wrong.
But then if you were to take them out of
that pain for a moment immediately
returns the filth of argument, the filth
of denial, the filth of lie
and deceit and treachery because it's
part of their soul. The only thing that
brings out good
is pain. And this is why they are damned
to this wretched place. May Allah
protect us. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us about the people of the
hellfire that if they when they are in
the hellfire they will say.
[Silence]
He said that if you could only see when
the people of hell are subjected to its
pain and torment that they will say
immediately, "If only we could go back
and believe in the verses and the
miracles and signs of our Lord and be
believers and followers of the
prophets." Allah says,
"Nay, they would never believe." He
says, "Rather,
this is a momentary
expression of what is truly concealed in
their hearts. But if they were really to
be sent back to the earth, they would go
right back to doing what they did
before." Could you imagine? Could you
imagine a soul so wicked, so hellbent
and hellbound
by evil and wretchedness that after
experiencing hell,
they would come back and still
eventually go right back into the old
habits? Could you imagine such a soul?
And so these are the damned. But the
people of hellfire,
they don't argue when they're in the
hellfire. Every one of them admits to
they're wrong. Outside of the hellfire,
they argue.
They argue and argue and argue. Just
likel,
he didn't just say he wasn't honest or
have the integrity to say I'm jealous.
I am angry. I am arrogant so I won't
bow. It's my arrogance really. This is
someone who could be rehabilitated
perhaps. However, what was his argument?
Oh, I'm better than him. I'm actually
created out of fire and he's created out
of clay and so you see this doesn't make
any logical sense and this actually
would demean me and so on and he's
arguing with Allah.
But this is how people reject the truth.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam defined
arrogance saying what?
That arrogance is the rejection of truth
and the belittlement of others.
Allah said about
that
he was too arrogant. Arrogance is what
stopped him from bowing to Adam.
It wasn't some moral code that he had.
It wasn't that he was bound by logic and
just didn't couldn't see why this was
the case. No. But people don't reject
the truth by saying I know this is the
truth, but I reject it. That's not how
people reject the truth. People reject
the truth with argument. People reject
the truth and belittle others with an
argument that makes it seem they
are coming from a logical perspective.
Even
what was his response about MS
and
let me kill MS and let's just get rid of
this guy. Why? Why does he want to kill
MS? Is it because he is he is jealous
of MS? He's afraid that he's not going
to be the Pharaoh anymore. He's afraid
that the party's going to come to an
end. That's really why. But what was his
argument?
I'm afraid that he's going to
you know change your religion. I'm
afraid that he's going to change our
ways and our culture. He's going to
separate. He's going to cause strife in
the families. He's going to break up our
togetherness and our unity. He's a
threat to our country. He's a threat to
our state and our government.
Right?
I'm afraid that MSA is going to spread
mischief and misguidance. That's why
it's not his arrogance. No, no. He's
worried about the people, right? Because
the hallmark of a tyrant
is always what? My people, my people.
That's the hallmark of a tyrant.
You want to know what a tyrant is? Is
someone who claims and screams the
loudest about the people. That is the
hallmark of a tyrant in the book of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. If you were
to ask Stalin or Hitler, if you were to
ask any of the most major tyrants in
history, many of them from our
countries, if you were to ask Pharaoh
himself,
what is your endgame? You would say, I
am a servant of the people. I'm only
here for the people. I love the people.
I fear for the people. I want to protect
the people. That is a tyrant. Exactly.
That is there. That is their day then as
Allah has told us in the Quran. We will
pick this up tomorrow.
Subhanah.
And
Subhan Allah.